[Music]
all right season 19 first double
eviction your reaction to Cody and Elena
out of the house well Cody was dead man
walking you knew it I knew it he knew it
everybody knew it but it's frustrating
because I know that a lot of the viewers
like Cody and if they already like him
based on what they saw which was kind of
a hothead right if he had just shown a
human face earlier and throughout the
game he could have lasted but you know I
think he was just happy to be away from
all those people I think he wanted to
get evicted and if not he would have
self inflicted with Elena Wow
you know right now mark and Elena they
did not have the numbers on their side
maybe the house right now they're just
following Paul's master plan Paul's
posse is going to have to turn on him
well maybe not him but they should you
know I want blindsides to happen within
a faction play the game play the game
yes do you think Paul's reappearance
this season has made the game or all
this year is Big Brother he's running
the show but it's a different guy than
we saw last year I wouldn't say he was
America's hero last year but he was a
fan favorite he's kind of the villain
this year who would you like to see step
up and run the game instead I hope Alex
does I would love for Alex
just take him as far as she needs him
and then cut him I feel as if she's more
loyal to Jason because if she's smart
she might be able to win more votes
against
well it's hard to say because people
always vote emotionally and and it
depends if one by one Paul's aussi as
they get evicted if they will Harbor bad
feelings towards them they might not
because he's such a good talker he'll
you know stab him to the front with a
smile they'll be like but but he showed
me he was coming for me he did it with a
smile he's not so bad he's just playing
the game I don't understand it what do
you think the game goes from here I
think it's going to be very predictable
mark will go next and then matter Raven
and then the real heat starts right now
it's all you got to stay out of the
crosshairs of Paul this jury do you
think it's going to be a bitter jury
well right now we have I think two
bitter people already in it but Cody
doesn't like anybody so what are you
gonna be bitter about you know he's I I
could see him at the end going like this
like mixing up the the keys and like I
don't care and not putting any thought
into it just to be like screw you I
think Elena can have like a mean bone in
there where she might be bitter